it's an act of defiance people living in
the Soraa neighborhood of Srinagar have
erected these barricades unlike the ones
put up by security forces to control the
movement of local people these have been
put up to keep the security forces out
for poor cutting here
or are there or Joey's kid you know they
come in violently the night before Eid
last week they blocked us in from four
directions and didn't let us pray in our
main mosque
they've also arrested boys and girls
from other areas so we have closed off
the entrance here this neighborhood has
been a flashpoint of several protests
since restrictions were imposed on
movement and communications after the
region's autonomy was revoked people
here worried that makes them a target if
we look at the present situation it
looks like they are going to address
every one of us Ghulam Botts brother was
detained on August 9th while returning
home from work his family only learned
of his arrest the next day since then
the frustration has only grown police
registered a case against him the cops
tell us to come in the morning and they
will release him when we do they tell us
to come in the evening this is what we
have been dealing with security forces
remain in the city and region in large
numbers Indian officials say there has
been some unrest in the past few days
but it's been relatively minor there was
a relaxation extended they also behave
normally also except few and few pockets
ever - to stray incidents of stone
pelting otherwise the rest of the area
behaved normally our situation is again
being monitored closely and local
decisions are taken regarding law and
order restrictions have been eased this
week with some people and vehicles
moving around
however most businesses in Srinagar
remain closed and in surah open defiance
remains in the sky above Srinagar we've
seen drones watching for protests which
have been spontaneous in different parts
of the city but here in surah
authorities already know people plan to
protest further and locals tell us they
plan to resist as long as they can as
Jamil al Jazeera Srinagar
indian-administered Kashmir